no federal bureaucrat played a bigger
role in 20th century law enforcement
than J Edgar Hoover who served as the
head of the FBI and its predecessor
Agency for half a century Hoover oversaw
crackdowns on everything from real and
imagined Communists in the first Red
Scare of the 1920s and its sequel in the
1950s staged high-profile shootouts with
Public Enemies like John Dillinger and
Babyface Nelson in the 1930s surveilled
Nazi and axis sympathizers during World
War II infiltrated the Ku Klux Klan and
pursued extra legal operations against
civil rights leaders and anti-war
protesters in the 1960s his personal
Vendetta against Martin Luther King Jr
led to one of the most shameful
incidents in FBI history when the bureau
sent an anonymous letter to King shortly
before he was to receive the Nobel Peace
Prize encouraging him to commit suicide
or be exposed as a serial philanderer
Hoover is the subject of Yale historian
Beverly Gage's new biography GMAT J
Edgar Hoover and the making of the
American Century Gage seeks to
complicate and flesh out the Life and
Legacy of Hoover who is rightly
notorious for often brushing aside
constitutional limits on state power
like so much police tape at a crime site
yet she points out that he opposed the
internment of Japanese Americans during
World War II undermine Senator Joe
McCarthy's overwrought anti-communist
witch hunts and refused to do political
surveillance for Richard Nixon
inadvertently leading to the bungled
Watergate break-ins and the 37th
president's Fall From Grace
I shall resign the presidency effective
at noon tomorrow
to understand Hoover in all his
complexity including his much whispered
about personal relationship with his FBI
colleague Clyde Tolson is to understand
the moral ambiguities of the country he
served Gage tells reason as well as to
understand the promise and limits of
constitutional government in an open
Society
[Music]
Beverly Gage thanks for talking to
reason
thanks for having me let's start with
the elevator pitch for uh G-Man Jagger
Hoover and the making of the American
Century what what how do you summarize
this book how do you pitch it to people
who should be interested in reading it
well it's been 30 years almost since the
last real crop of Hoover biographies so
part of the goal is just to have a
chance to look at all of the records all
of the new history all of the new ways
of thinking that have come out over
these decades but I guess I had two
goals in mind one is to get away from
what I think is a little bit of our
caricature of Hoover as this kind of
one-dimensional villain this figure who
stood outside of American politics
manipulating everyone and actually bring
him back into kind of a central part of
the story of the 20th century
um and then also to situate him in a
couple of political Traditions that we
don't often think of as going together
in our own moment one is a kind of
progressive good government expert
bureaucrat tradition and the other is a
kind of deep social conservatism and
then think about the ways that those two
fit together in his life and then shaped
a lot of the 20th century can you uh
dilate on that a little bit because this
is something at reason we tend to take a
a fairly dark view of the progressive
period partly because it was so socially
conservative and reactionary uh you know
when you think about things like alcohol
prohibition
um you know at on the one hand uh the
progressives were pushing for women's
rights in certain areas and in other
ways they were trying to kind of control
female sexuality in in new and
emboldened ways
um certainly with immigration there was
a progressive fixation on Purity and
cleanliness that led to a lot of
anti-anti-immigrant uh sentiments and
whatnot so talk a little bit about
Hoover you know as he emerges because uh
he was born what in uh what year was he
born again so he was born 1895 and he
really came of age then in the
Progressive Era and entered government
in in 1917 in sort of the peak year of
progressivism in many ways which is
amazing Joseph I'm sorry I mean it's it
is amazing when you look at the to get
you know I mean it would be as if Babe
Ruth was still playing baseball in you
know the early 70s or something you know
just that span and I want to talk with
you a little bit about uh you know that
term in your subtitle the American
Century but so Hoover is growing up he's
he's a Washington DC Hometown guy what
does it mean to be growing up in the
early 1900s yeah one of the things that
attracted me to writing about him is as
you suggest this huge span of time he he
enters the justice department in 1917
becomes head of the bureau in 1924 and
then is there through 1972 right so it's
just this incredible career this
incredible period of time
um which we'll we'll get to but the
Progressive Era is I think really
critical for understanding him for some
of the reasons and in some ways kind of
contradictory reasons or tensions that
are established during that period
um he's born 1895 he's born in
Washington and he's born into these two
Traditions that become so important to
him one is this kind of career
government service even in the late 19th
century he's born to a family that has
worked in the career government service
the administrative wing of the state
already and that's not very big in the
late 19th Century um and then he's born
into Washington as a conservative
southern city so particularly on the
question of race he is born into a city
that is actively undergoing racial
segregation uh where there's a lot of
talk about cleanliness and Order and the
good Society being linked to these ideas
about racial separation and segregation
and he holds on to many of these ideas
for the rest of his life yeah one of the
things that comes through is uh you know
in in profound ways not maybe total ways
but in profound ways he is a southerner
um you know and he was born the year
before Plessy versus Ferguson so kind of
you know the the uh you know legal
articulation of Jim Crow
um and
um you know at the same time DC was a
city that was mixing right because one
of one of the odd things is that it
takes Woodrow Wilson you know 15 20
years years later to desegregate the
federal Workforce implying that blacks
and whites were actually kind of working
and living together in you know in a in
a way that seems kind of difficult to
understand right now right the the city
that he was born into the Washington of
the late 19th century was really a
multi-racial city and I was able to kind
of look at the census and build out a
little bit of his childhood neighborhood
and it was a multi-racial neighborhood
but by the time we get into the teens
you're seeing this very very firm
process of segregation taking place and
as you say it's during the Wilson years
that federal employment becomes much
more explicitly segregated than it had
been before and those are the years that
Hoover enters government service and you
talk uh he went to George Washington uh
University I I does George Washington
and I guess he went to their Law School
in particular although it's you know
back then what I mean he seemed to go
directly from high school to to law
school right so it's a little bit
different than today's academic kind of
progression is George Washington
University proud of of having him as an
Alum or are they kind of like uh you
know on the one hand you know world's
greatest bureaucrat on the other hand
he's Jagger Hoover right well they still
listen among their famous alums
um so he's still out
BW was a was a different institution at
the time it really was mostly a night
school it was a professional School you
went particularly into a professional
track as your undergraduate training and
most of what it did was train for
service in the government so it was a
lot of local students who were like
Hoover working for the government during
the day he worked at the Library of
Congress been attending GW at night he
uh one of the things that his college
Years that you stress a lot is that he
was a member of a fraternity that was
chartered in the in the Deep South and
embraced a kind of lost cause Southern
uh Romanticism can you talk a little bit
about what that fraternity was and and
how it kind of
um structured or gave voice either I
don't know if it it created these ideas
in him or gave voice to them or
something but could you talk a little
bit about that yeah in the college he
joined this fraternity call called Kappa
Alpha became the chapter president at GW
and remained pretty involved in and
committed to the fraternity throughout
his life in fact took some of the first
generation of FBI agents and officials
out of the circle of Kappa Alpha as well
as GW and so I wanted to know what this
institution really was and it was
fascinating as I started to do the
research because it turns out Kappa
Alpha is a fraternity that was founded
as you say kind of in the aftermath of
the Civil War to carry on the Lost Cause
of Robert E Lee of the white South and
by the time Hoover joined it in the
teens you know at the height of kind of
segregation Jim Crow being ensconced a
lot of its most famous members were
these Ardent segregationists the one
that really fascinated me was a guy
named Thomas Dixon who was a famous
novel list wrote the novels that the
film Birth of a Nation was based on this
kind of famously racist romanticization
of the Ku Klux Klan and so what was
particularly interesting there is that I
could see the world that was kind of
creating Hoover's racial ideology which
of course becomes so important to the
way that he polices uh social movements
politics and it's amazing because uh
Dixon's novel the main one that Birth of
a Nation is based on is called the
klansmen uh there's the rise of the
second Clan and then Hoover becomes kind
of famous and we'll get to this down the
road for actually kind really
undercutting the clan
um you know by the mid 60s or so
um what can you you know to go back to
this question of progressivism and kind
of order and cleanliness or Purity
versus kind of chaos or mixing and
mongrelization what is going on there
and is it is it is the ratio is
maintaining strict racial borders is
that the basis of uh you know the world
view or is that an epiphenomenon is that
something you know that what
progressives wanted more than anything
else and I realized you know I'm
painting with a broad brusher and
generally a negative one but you know
they wanted order first and foremost and
so when it comes to things like
drunkenness you know that takes one form
when it comes to
um you know the way government uh
administers itself that takes one form
and then when it comes to things like
race relations or racial and ethnic
heterogeneity versus homogeneity it it
really argues for kind of fixed
boundaries
yeah I think historians spend a lot of
time trying to sort out what
progressivism actually was and of course
it's this big tent it's got all sorts of
movements in it it's got all sorts of
ideas
um I think for Hoover growing up during
the Progressive Era there are a couple
of really important ideas uh that come
out of it so one is this faith in kind
of experts in people who are going to
stand apart from politics and in many
ways apart from democratic forms who are
going to be able to kind of control
situations administer the government but
a whole world of kind of expertise and
professionalism that emerges I think as
a young boy he's also growing up with
ideas about a kind of progressive
orderly self-disciplined masculinity
that is just all over the literature of
this period at his church in his high
school elsewhere and the essential idea
idea that I think a lot of progressives
held that individual virtue the ability
to discipline yourself to act in certain
ways was going to be really critical to
the social order and then in fact the
state had a role in encouraging and
enforcing certain kinds of behavior on
that front could you talk a little bit
about the masculinity crisis that was
you know widely discussed in the early
20th century because as I was reading
that I was like holy you know obviously
history you know what is it a history it
doesn't repeat itself but it Rhymes but
I'm hearing you know a lot of the same
thing that as as the country was moving
from the from rural to Urban uh as new
types of people were coming in there you
know as men were leaving Farms or
physical labor and doing desk jobs
because of industrialization you know
there was a sense that they didn't know
how to be manly and that's a big problem
yeah that is really one of the Dom
dominant themes in every institution
that I was able to kind of research
about Hoover's early years the D.C
public schools and then George
Washington University Kappa Alpha but
also you know the Presbyterian Church
where he comes of age right this is a
moment when there are worries first of
all the boys aren't going to school and
schools aren't suiting boys very well in
fact it appears that at Hoover's own
public high school white public high
school and Washington girls outnumbered
boys two to one so there's a lot of
attention on the boys about how are we
going to turn these boys into men a
certain suspicion actually of the things
that Hoover was really good at because
he was like he was a paperwork kid he
was a brainy kid he wasn't very sporty
in certain ways he didn't really fit
into this ideal of uh kind of muscular
uh masculinity or muscular Christianity
certainly the I mean he's short too
right relatively speaking and you know
the pictures of him as a round person I
mean it's uh you know these I don't
think we're quite making those body
types anymore which is is a good thing
for for men and women I suspect right
well that was later in his life he was a
very you know trim kind of uh you know
he was not an athlete per se because he
was small but he did uh he was in what
like a drum not a drum major but a
regimen right
yeah in high schools pretty common at
the time uh it's a little bit like ROTC
but but less formal than that so uh yeah
he was very into kind of military drill
uh and those were the kinds of
Institutions he always liked you know
they were full of hierarchy and rules
and Order
um he really enjoyed institutions where
he was kind of both uh close with other
men and engaged in some common purpose
at a lot of those institutions of his
youth his return Unity the Cadet Corps
you can see the ways in which they
become models for what he builds at the
bureau and you know this is not a uh a
strict in any way should I perform a
kind of psychoanalytic biography but you
do dwell on his home life uh with
extremely chaotic and it was filled with
um you know both kind of overbearing
female figures to or certainly in the
case of his mother but then
um also like non you know kind of
non-entity men or men who are constantly
breaking down right uh physically and
and mentally
yeah well I think that's a little bit
uncharitable to his mother maybe yes who
had a lot going on and uh and yeah no
she certainly was yes yeah truly but but
it was really interesting to me to see
you know Hoover often narrated his
childhood as this kind of idyllic time
um and I was able to kind of go back and
interrogate that a little bit and find
some really pretty deep family traumas
from the suicide of one of his
grandfathers a pretty public suicide he
drowned himself in the Anacostia River
uh to the murder of his mother's
brother's wife
um again you know headlines and that was
when he was 10 years old so he certainly
knew about that and then what I I
concluded and you know some of this is a
little speculation but had to be one of
the most important factors in his
childhood which is that his father
suffered from depression and so you know
he's in a world where he's under all of
this pressure getting all of these
messages about what a man is supposed to
be and his own father he was really
struggling he's struggling with mental
illness in other ways as well
it I mean it does uh create uh you know
a sympathetic view of of
um Hoover or or at least as you move
through his life you realize uh you know
this guy was dealing with a ton of stuff
um not usually not explicitly or at
least not maybe not consciously but not
publicly uh let's talk about his early
years in the service his his kind of and
to skip ahead a little bit but his can
you talk about his role in uh you know
what came to be known as the Palmer
Raids and and the first Red Scare
um what was going on there and why is
that so important to the person that uh
and the bureaucrat and the the power
person that uh Hoover became
yeah Hoover happened to graduate from
Law School in 1917 which is one of these
kind of accidents of history that made
me think well you know had it been a
year earlier a few years later would we
have had a different J Edgar Hoover a
different American state a different
sense of history but he graduated just
just States was entering World War One
uh he did not enter the military but
instead went straight into the justice
department and spent a couple of years
there basically helping to administer
German internment and German
registration Richard thinks we don't
think about much now but we're a pretty
big deal at the time and it turned out
that he was good enough at that sort of
paperwork and at that sort of kind of
early surveillance experiment that in
1919 when the federal government decides
that they're going to kind of keep some
of this going in peace time particularly
to a police political radicals like
anarchists and Communists and other
revolutionaries right moment of big
turmoil Hoover gets the job as the head
of the new radical division in the
justice department and the radical
division basically has two jobs one is
to start building up a file system
that's going to keep track of basically
left Wingers throughout the country a
few exceptions to that but mostly
anarchists and Communists and then to
help plan for deportation raids that
ultimately happen at the end of 1919 and
early 1920 that become known as the
Palmer Raids and I think there are a
couple of things that are really
critical about the Palmer Raids and
about that moment that he carries on
through his life so one is that he
becomes one of the first government
experts on communism he actually writes
the First Federal briefs on the two
communist parties that form in 1919 and
so he sort of sells himself as an expert
there as the only man who kind of
understands this revolutionary ferment
the Bolshevik Revolution had just
happened in Russia and then the second
is that he gets in a lot of trouble
ultimately for the Palmer Raids or at
least comes under a lot of criticism
they're very popular at first and then
after the second round of raids mainly
civil liberty ontarians come forth and
say we don't think this is something you
know the state should be doing against
people who are basically just expressing
unpopular political ideas and and it's
hard to I mean kind of fully capture how
kind of insane they uh wartime
restrictions on Free Speech work right I
mean Wilson and you know again this is
shows the kind of multifacetedness of
the Progressive Movement because on the
one hand you have Woodrow Wilson the
Paragon of progressivism basically
saying anybody who disagreed about
entering the War uh you know should be
put in jail for treason or or whatever
sedition and then you have these early
groups like the ACLU and the double a
little bit later the NAACP who are also
Progressive saying no we should not be
surveilling people in peacetime who are
just going about kind of General
political organizing exactly and this is
the moment
um at Hoover's you know first moment in
government but it's also so for many of
the same uh reasons it's the birth of a
kind of civil liberties Consciousness
the ACLU itself as an organization comes
out of this period and of course you
know Hoover is kind of negotiating with
uh being criticized by accommodating
um critics like the ACLU for for the
rest of his career
now Hoover though politically seemed to
be more in line with the Republican
party and I realize also during the
Progressive here in particular somebody
like Theodore Roosevelt you know it's
Theodore Roosevelt and um you know when
Woodrow Wilson ultimately probably have
more in common than you know any two
Democrats or any two Republicans but
what happens in the 20s because you know
Wilson is out you have Harding and then
Coolidge come in does that give
uh but these guys are also particularly
Coolidge is anti I mean he's
anti-immigrant but he's also anti-giving
the federal government any power how
does hoover kind of maneuver the 20s
where on the one hand he's given a lot
of room to go after Reds because
communism is the big threat and
especially as the Soviet Union really
kind of gets up and running during the
20s there's that but then there's this
suspicion of the federal government and
particularly a federal law enforcement I
mean this is another thing
um looking back before say the uh you
know FDR or something the federal
government was a relatively small player
in almost everything but certainly in
things like law enforcement
yeah that's definitely true you know
Hoover politically is you know an
interesting character and one of the
reasons I wanted to write about him was
that I think he kind of gives us a
different lens onto the story of
politics and government because he's a
DC resident so it means he never votes
in his life he never formally joins a
political party and in some ways the big
story of his career is his ability to
move back and forth between these
Democratic and Republican
administrations you know just during his
time at the bureau he's there under
eight different presidents four of them
are Republicans four of them are
Democrats and then you see that even
earlier he starts out in the Wilson
Administration and he successfully
transitions into the Harding
Administration and then uh into Coolidge
and what makes his ability to last
through those years kind of even more
remarkable early on is that you know he
really does come under criticism for the
palm of raids and Palmer is ousted but
when the new Administration comes in he
actually gets a promotion so he becomes
the assistant director of The Bureau and
again because I think he was really
talented at Administration and making
the bureaucracy run getting the files in
order professionalizing hiring and
firing and scientific methods and
fingerprinting and all of these things
that he embraced but then there are a
bunch of scandals in the 20s under the
Harding Administration so that attorney
general gets kicked out that bureau
chief gets kicked out and yet Hoover
survives again and in 1924 though he had
been sort of adjacent to some of those
scandals uh he is in fact made director
of The Bureau
and this is you know later in his life
you know the the common line which seems
to have some truth to it is that you
know he had so much dirt on any
president that it would be hard to you
know for a president to fire him because
they'd be afraid of reprisals at this
point he's not really doing that so is
he just uh as you said I mean he's he's
a good bureaucrat in the sense that he's
taking these offices and kind of
professionalizing them he's coming up
with kinds of conduct and and best
operating procedures and things like
that is that what accounts for
um you know his ability to kind of get
to a point where the modern FBI or the
or the FBI is fully created with him at
the head of it yeah I think so I mean
our image of him you know kind of
manipulating and strong arming and using
gossip to bend people to his will all of
that which does happen in later years
doesn't actually tell us very much about
this early period when he doesn't have
that kind of power and he can't do it
and I think the reason that he is in
fact successful uh in 1924 and then
during this kind of period of
institution building in the 20s so he's
really good at pleasing men a level or
two above him so he's always throughout
his career very good at reading what
more powerful men want from him and
trying to deliver that
um he's very good at running his
bureaucracy and he's kind of you know
this young energetic figure
um who holds a lot of appeal and he
spends a lot of that first period as
director trying to get away from the
scandals of the earlier period so he
promises he's not going to do political
surveillance anymore or but more or less
sticks to that I mean there are some
exceptions but certainly in comparison
to the Red Scare he really follows
through and that he is going to make his
men you know Incorruptible getting away
from like all the poker games and
whiskey dealing of the Harding
Administration and those ideas really
kind of drive him for that first decade
when the bureau is pretty small he's
just kind of refining the bureaucracy
and his own ideas when the you know in
the 30s
um you know there's there's two things
that that start to crop up one I mean
there's a there's a continuing worry
about Communists uh but then the rise of
fascists um both overseas but at home
and then there's the rise not quite of
organized crime in terms of you know the
mafia or whatever we can get to that in
a little bit but of you know the the
high profile tabloid gangsters people
like Babyface Nelson and Ma Barker and
John Dillinger how does
um you know how how does uh Hoover
negotiated navigate the 30s particularly
first with this organized crime thing
and and in the book you you know you you
stress or you point out that a lot of
the things that we take for granted that
the FBI would be involved in you know
they kind of had to make a case for that
and also he was in many ways slow to
kind of expand the purview I you know I
believe in public Choice economics so I
think every government agency is always
trying to increase its market share kind
of like a private business but there are
moments where it seems like he's really
being he's trying to be restrained but
then he gets pushed into doing more and
more as the head of the Federal Bureau
of Investigation
yeah I think uh kind of contrary to our
image of Hoover as constantly trying to
you know uh find new duties accumulate
more power he was actually pretty
selective about the sorts of things that
he would take on and during his first
decade as director when the bureau
doesn't have very much jurisdiction uh
his main goal is to create this kind of
world of scientific gentleman expert
investigators who are going to wear
suits and they're going to you know deal
with things like statistics and
fingerprints but they're not going to be
like cops right they're not going to be
out there doing that sort of thing then
the 30s comes along and the 30s as you
say is really the critical period where
the FBI gets the two big duties that
come to Define it for the rest of
Hoover's career and I think even today
uh one is that they become a real
federal law enforcement agency see under
all of this pressure from the Roosevelt
administration but also just from the
the situation this rise in violent crime
that takes place and these big celebrity
criminals uh he sort of gets pushed into
that and it's interesting to watch how
quickly uh his bureaucracy then is able
to turn his agents mostly didn't even
carry guns or not as a regular feature
before this moment suddenly they're
carrying guns they're engaging in these
high-profile public shootouts with
people like John Dillinger sometimes
they're really screwing it up at first
um and then they ultimately come through
and then the other thing that happens as
you say in the 30s is that they move
back into Political surveillance in a
much more aggressive way and yes let's
let's get to that in a second I just
want to on the the Dillinger suffer you
know this is probably my parents were
born in the 20s and so they I mean they
grew up in the 30s and they would talk
about you know these kinds of gun
battles and things like that
um there's a figure who I think used to
be better known as he's receding from
history that you talk about Melvin
Purvis who was he and why is he
important to you know kind of
understanding the way Hoover operates as
head of the as head of the bureau
Melvin Purvis to your parents would have
been most famous as the agent who took
down John Dillinger and so you know in
1935 36 uh he is really Hoover's only
rival uh Hoover is just becoming a
celebrity Melvin Purvis is becoming a
celebrity but to me the most interesting
thing is the period before that Hoover
hired Purvis as an almost perfect
example of the kind of man that he liked
to hire at the bureau he was young he
was good looking he was Southern he was
a Kappa Alpha coming out of that
fraternity and then from a historian's
perspective what's really fascinating
about Purvis is that he saved all of his
correspondence with Hoover and so it's
remarkable correspondence because you
can see this young agent who's not only
Rising through the ranks of the bureau
but is negotiating a pretty intimate
personal relationship with his boss
sometimes it's kind of flirtatious
sometimes it just has a quality of a
kind of Boss pressuring and underlaying
to be more casual and purpose being like
but I really think I should call you
director and he says no call me J.E and
so it's just a fascinating set of
personal correspondence and we don't
have a lot of that for Hoover because he
had a lot of his personal papers
destroyed
but then
um Purvis basically he becomes too big a
star right he doesn't know his place
within the bureau's hierarchy right it's
a pretty uh conflict-filled and in some
ways kind of tragic ending for Purvis so
Hoover fires him uh in 1936 kind of the
wake of all the Dillinger stuff it seems
clear some of it is jealousy some of it
is that Purvis is also you know not
following Hoover's rules all the time
um and it's a pretty profound personal
break and Hoover really refuses to talk
to him for decades
um and uh and in the early 60s Purvis
ends up uh committing suicide and Hoover
refuses even to acknowledge it then
um the other big thing and I you know
particularly for the way we talk about
the FBI now is that um you know FDR
comes a calling or I mean you know it's
obviously much more complicated than
that and it's like you know we need you
to start doing surveillance of political
groups or ideological groups can you
describe how that happens and you know
how does Hoover respond to that
FDR was probably the most important
president in Hoover's career although it
wasn't he wasn't the president that
Hoover was personally closest to but
he's really important because he gives
Hoover all of the tools that are the
building blocks of the FBI one of those
is that in the mid 30s as you say as uh
communist groups but particularly
concerns about domestic fascism are
picking up
um as worries about kind of Labor Strife
throughout the country are getting more
and more attention FDR basically goes to
Hoover and says hey could you maybe keep
an eye on all of these groups for me and
very quietly really without the
knowledge of Congress allows the bureau
to move back into that kind of political
investigation political surveillance uh
that then becomes formalized during the
war and and absolutely explodes during
the war the war the FBI quadruples
inside eyes starts doing all sorts of
new kinds of work that don't go away
when the war ends are they are they
actually good at infiltrating
uh you know the groups that are serious
because you know this comes up later
certainly in the 60s and with cointelpro
um but you know in the in the 30s and
40s were they finding those secret Nazi
saboteurs or those
um you know Sinister communist groups
that were undermining America from with
that
well one of the things that they have to
do is actually figure out how to do that
kind of work so political surveillance
is one thing but Espionage and counter
Espionage real wartime intelligence work
they actually have no idea how to do it
and there is nobody in the United States
that has any idea really how to do this
um and so uh during the early years they
turned to the British and the British
are the ones that really kind of teach
both the FBI and then later the OSS uh
precursor of the CIA to do a lot of the
things that are necessary during wartime
and as they're getting started sorry oh
no I I was going to say you described an
incident though where they did I guess
uh get uh you know they they penetrated
a group of Nazi Affiliated you know
agents I guess spies or uh saboteurs
whatever subversives but then they
treated them as if they were criminals
right and they like released them after
they were indicted or something like
that I mean they were like Okay show up
for your trial and most of them
obviously left the country right in the
late 30s as they're just learning to do
this they're kind of acting like the law
enforcement officials they are and not
you know like counter-terrorism or
counter Espionage uh operatives and so
yeah in their early cases some of which
were really quite embarrassing
um they do things like go ahead and
arrest everyone and then tell them to
promise to show back up for the grand
jury of course
of course they'll all go back to Germany
but they do learn as the war goes along
they have a big high profile case in
1942 that I dedicated chapter two that
involves kind of an amazing story of uh
German saboteurs who were brought over
on U-boats you know dropped off on the
beach in Florida and Long Island and
it's a it's kind of a big detective Saga
of sorts that ends with their capture
and execution
and um also in the 30s and this is
partly due to the the organized crime
suffer or you know the Dillinger Alvin
karpus type people who for fans of
bizarre American history Alvin carpis
shows up later teaching Charles Manson
how to play guitar and federal PR uh is
that right I didn't know yeah yeah
there's so many bizarre connections
through all of this kind of stuff but
Hoover also starts using confidential
informants can you talk a little bit
about how that was a change in how that
became super important to the FBI's kind
of uh Mo going forward
yeah when Hoover became director
um he had all of these things that he
promised he was never going to do he was
never going to wiretap he was never
going to use kind of strong arm or third
degree tactics you know physical force
and he was not going to use informers
because they were you know kind of just
untrustworthy Etc well a lot of these as
he gets into much more serious both
intelligence and law enforcement work a
lot of those promises Fall by the
wayside but he has a really interesting
policy that he does hold for almost all
of his career which is that he does not
want his own agents going undercover in
the way that we might think about you
know an actual employee of the bureau
pretending to be someone else going
undercover what they got very good at
doing although you know there are ups
and downs along the way
um was uh either paying regular citizens
to go ahead and join fascist groups
communist groups whatever group they
might deem suspect or recruiting people
who were inside those groups of course
to inform on their comrades and
colleagues
after
um
you know uh FDR says you've got to help
rid us of domestic fascism and you know
and and the return of kind of
surveillance of political groups
um is there any turning back then does
that become uh you know an inextricable
part of the FBI's day-to-day operations
it really does uh most of the programs
and strategies and methods that are put
in place during the war simply continue
on and in certain cases escalate after
the war so the targets change a little
bit because you know once the war is
over there's a lot less concern with uh
with fascists with
um you know Japanese loyalists of those
interests sort of die away but what
really persists is is the FBI
surveillance of of the left in general
and that's one of the weird ironies or I
don't know if it's an irony or if it's
weird but that in the 30s uh number of
we're going to say or a number of things
to strategies to surveil usually German
Allied groups I like the the Bund
movement and whatnot
um oftentimes with the support of either
Communists in America or communist
sympathizers in Congress and whatnot end
up being turned that surveillance state
or apparatus ends up being turned
against Soviet people or or suspected
Soviets uh spy sympathizers and later in
the 40s and 50s right I mean there's
this fascinating period from 1939 to
1941 which is the period of the Nazi
Soviet pact and that's when the FBI is
really ramping up and they're looking
again both at fascists and at Communists
it's kind of Soviet connections but of
course in 1941 then the Soviet Union
becomes an American Ally but the FBI
actually doesn't stop doing what it was
already doing and and it's that that
continues on and then Becomes of course
the Redskins care after the war
what is uh there's there's a moment
around this time uh that you mentioned
in the book too that
um kind of Communism or political
subversion could be fascists but it's
mostly communist and homosexuality or
you know sexual deviancy or
alternativeness they get yoked together
um was that true in um in Hoover's mind
the idea that homosexuals and Communists
or subversives are almost always the
same thing
yeah there are these two quote unquote
scares that happened in the 40s and 50s
one is the Red Scare which is aimed at
Communists leftists in general and then
the other is the lavender scare which
was aimed at gay people primarily
employed in the federal government and
it became federal policy in the 40s 50s
and into the 60s that you if you were
found to be gay uh you could be and
would be fired from your job in the
federal government
um and so there are all sorts of ways in
which these things are kind of connected
in the language and the images of the
time right these are both whether you're
a communist or you're gay you're you're
keeping secrets and those secrets are
making you vulnerable and your loyalties
might lie elsewhere right in the case of
uh quote unquote homosexuals the idea
was that you could be blackmailed
because you had this dangerous secret
right so there's a lot of cultural
imagery that sort of links these two
groups Hoover interestingly I would say
treats them the same and different so he
enforces federal policy and so the FBI
is you know conducting pretty extensive
investigations of people's sex lives as
well as their political backgrounds
during these years and often getting
people fired from their jobs but Hoover
is much much more outspoken publicly
about anti-communism he talks very
rarely about homosexuality and that is
in part uh because it wasn't his core
interest but it was in part because he
himself uh was primarily living in a
world with other men having a
relationship uh with another man and
um you know was vulnerable to all sorts
of rumors about his own sexuality
um uh we will talk about that and the uh
cocktail dress uh myths and whatnot in a
moment but um one of the things both in
the 40s and the 50s during the uh
McCarthy period but even during World
War II and you know you said your one of
your goals and you certainly do this uh
in writing the book is to complicate
Hoover's Legacy he is on the right side
of the koramatsu decision uh you know he
was against interning Japanese Americans
uh any you know the people on the other
side included people like Earl Warren
you know a governor of California who
was Progressive uh you know as well as
Franklin Roosevelt what was his
rationale and why was he you know on a
certain level why was he so good on that
and then so bad in so many other ways
yeah it's a great you know it's one of J
Edgar Hoover's better moments which is
that in 1942 he opposes Mass internment
of of Japanese Americans so why does he
do that because it seems kind of counter
to our vision of Hoover
um and I think there are a couple of
reasons the first is that he genuinely
thought it was unconstitutional
um particularly when you were talking
about American citizens and that's about
half of the people who were entered were
in fact American citizens and he would
just thought you couldn't do that he
thought it was unconstitutional and he
thought it wouldn't really stand the
test of History very well I think he was
looking back to moments like World War
One and the Palmer Raids where he had
been involved in programs that came
under a lot of criticism
um and he could sort of see that coming
with Japanese internment probably the
most important reason slightly less
principled reason was that the FBI and
the justice department were already
running their own internment program and
so they had a very specific vision of
how that ought to run so they were
looking not only at uh Japanese people
but at people of German descent and
people with Italian descent and they
were making individual cases against
them and that's how he thought it ought
to go that there were people who were
dangers
disloyal during wartime but that the FBI
could tell you who they were that these
cases ought to be made individually and
that everybody else didn't need to to
worry about it because Jay Edgar Hoover
was on the case so that's where uh you
know his professionalism and his you
know his belief and his own expertise
and his own systems really trumps uh
larger scale kind of uh anxieties or
hysterities do you know offhand um you
know how many Japanese or how many
italian either probably not
Italian-American citizens but Italian
resident aliens or German resident
aliens what numbers were being put into
uh relocation camps or internment camps
during World War II yeah I don't know
the final numbers but it's in the
thousands
um and you're right so they are all
non-citizens uh who are being interned
in in various ways
um I think my impression just from
looking at the FBI's own early numbers
and this would have been early on is
that the number of Japanese were higher
was higher uh than either Germans or
Italians but there are substantial
numbers of Germans and Italians who are
sent uh to camps sometimes families uh
but often just uh individuals
um in the 50s
um you know he was also kind of on or
you know he he was not an ally of Joe
McCarthy or of the most kind of insane
overwrought hysterical witch hunts for
Communists where did that come from and
and how did he you know your book does a
good job of this of how did he undermine
Joe McCarthy while not becoming a target
of McCarthy's wrath yeah when we think
about the the McCarthy era right
obviously McCarthy is the figure we tend
to think of but I think Hoover was much
more important uh in a couple of ways so
he uh really takes anti-communism as the
cause of his life and it makes him
incredibly popular in the 40s and 50s
he's doing that work before McCarthy
comes along he's doing it while
McCarthy's there and he's doing it after
McCarthy has been kind of censored and
driven out of political life but and he
is if I I'm sorry to interrupt I mean at
certain points it seems that he
interprets any disagreement with him
about what it means to be American or
whatever as it means you're a communist
I mean that's one of the odd things
about Hoover it seems like at a certain
point it becomes impossible to disagree
with him and him not to cast that in
archley ideological terms yeah and I
think there are two things going on
there one is that he just hated
criticism he had a powerful sense of his
own righteousness and his own rightness
and he really went after people who
criticized him for any reason and that
is true throughout his career
um and then second he just had an
incredibly expansive vision of what the
struggle against communism meant so it
you know I think we could imagine an FBI
director in the 40s and 50s it's the
early Cold War you know the Communist
party is in fact getting money and
support from the Soviet Union there is
in fact some level of Soviet Espionage
so anyone in this position is going to
be doing some of that but you could
think of someone who would just kind of
take it as a national security matter
right conduct these Espionage
investigations Etc and be done with it
but Hoover did something very very
different which was to kind of frame it
in these you know Grand existential
terms we are battling atheistic
communism and therefore all Americans
should be going to church and
participating in religious rituals you
know etc etc and so we had a highly
expansive very moralistic vision of what
all of this meant yeah and if you didn't
agree with him he then found you suspect
so how did he uh kind of stick the knife
in Joe McCarthy though because you know
McCarthy was also you know as Ardent a
uh right so they certainly shared a lot
of ideas and they were actually pretty
friendly with each other in a social
sense they you know hung out with the
same people often
um but Hoover did not like McCarthy
because he thought he was sort of a
loose cannon uh he thought that he lied
he thought that he was uh you know a
headline monger and a demagogue and he
thought therefore that McCarthy was
actually doing a lot of danger to the
anti-communist cause the thing that he
least liked about McCarthy was that
McCarthy kept trying to kind of take the
credibility of the FBI to back up his
own claims so he would say things like
you know there are these Communists in
the state department and if we can open
up the FBI files I guarantee they will
show what I'm saying of course that is
the last thing that that Hoover the
institution Builder wants so he works uh
at various moments from 1950 to 54
particularly with the Eisenhower
Administration to sort of say nope
actually the FBI Files won't necessarily
support what Joe McCarthy is claiming
and that really helps to discredit him
and bring him down
um
towards the you know in in the 50s the
other thing that kind of gets uh you
know gets up and running in a big way is
the civil rights movement and this goes
back to uh earlier concerns that Hoover
had events uh you know about race mixing
and things like that but there and there
are I mean to be fair to the historical
record there are there were Communists
who were involved in the mainstream
Civil Rights Movement including people
who were Associates of Martin Luther
King and things like that but you get to
this point then where uh Hoover is
identifying the civil rights movement or
any kind of desegregation efforts as a
communist plot to overturn and Destroy
America can you talk a little bit about
how he built that case both in his own
head and it wasn't just him I mean this
is you know Common of a lot of people
who are you know Democrats and
Republicans at the time but Southern
Democrats see you know somehow the
um the institution of segregation and
americanism were conflated and so if you
were for integration you were
anti-American which also meant then you
were a communist what what was going on
there and how did that affect the way
that Hoover focused uh the attentions of
the FBI
well I think
on race and on many other
s to just think of Hoover as essentially
a defender of the status quo and so
social movements organizations forms of
protest that were seeking to upend power
relations existing social hierarchies he
tended to be very suspicious of
um and the Civil Rights Movement I would
say above all you know in fact if you
look at his career nobody
absorbed the weight and the cruelty and
the power of the FBI as much as black
radicals of one sort or another from the
mainstream Civil Rights Movement into
the Communist party you know later the
Black Power movement the Nation of Islam
uh a lot of the FBI's energy and
capacity was always aimed at those
groups and figures who Hoover saw as
this deep threat to you know everything
from from the racial order to the
workings of American politics to Simply
his friends who were Southern and
Democrats there are some interesting
moments where he makes exceptions to
that pattern in the 40s he does begin to
investigate lynchings in the south in
part because he thinks that that kind of
violence is a challenge to Federal
authority to Federal legitimacy and he
does some of that in in the 60s as well
but the overall pattern is pretty
distinct and yeah at one point you
mentioned that when he finally kind of
gets motivated to go against the Ku Klux
Klan and I guess in the 60s really part
of it is because he was thinking of them
he was linking them to Black radicals
and that they were both operating
outside the law uh you know and it's
it's a bizarre kind of equation
certainly a moral equivalency that
doesn't pass the laugh test but the way
he could find it within him to push
against the Ku Klux Klan and said these
guys are acting you know they're
Mavericks they're outside the law just
like the Black Panther Party or or the
uh Snick the SNCC
right if Hoover focused almost all of
his energies on you know the left writ
large particularly uh on the Civil
Rights Movement as it began to emerge in
the 50s
um but there were these moments uh where
if you met one of two criteria or really
both criteria
um he might go after white supremacist
groups Neo-Nazi groups um other kind of
far-right groups as well one was the use
of violence um the other was kind of
thumbing their nose at Federal Authority
and you know a lot of massive resistance
in the South a lot of what the clan was
doing was saying you know the federal
government can't come into the South and
enforce civil rights law and in those
moments Hoover said oh yeah really well
you know watch us do it um so there were
those exceptions but uh with the Civil
Rights Movement it was a much broader
right he Associated it with Communism uh
he Associated it with uh kind of
embarrassing the United States on the
world stage and providing Soviet
propaganda he didn't like Civil
Disobedience which he saw as a forum of
law breaking there was just a basic
level of racism behind all of this and
so it's all in this big stew and then of
course with uh with King this escalates
and escalates in really dramatic ways
yeah and it is kind of amazing to think
uh you know with somebody like Martin
Luther King or Civil Disobedience and
the way the king practiced it was that
you took your punishment I mean that was
the the moral part of it and he's
drawing from Henry David Thoreau as much
as anybody so it's a form of political
protest that is so American for Hoover
to be like this is anti-American you
know he's doing a lot of mental
gymnastics there I first uh I think I
first became aware of your work about a
decade ago you were you found in
unredacted version of the letter that
the FBI or some somebody within the FBI
or associated with the FBI sent to
Martin Luther King
urging him to commit suicide up you know
when he was a month away from receiving
the Nobel Peace Prize in what was 64. I
guess yeah could you describe what that
letter you know where did it come from
what did it say and how does that kind
of exemplify Hoover's you know weird
Obsession and fixation on Martin Luther
King in particular
yeah that is probably the best thing I'm
ever going to find in an archive I
thought well this is sort of you know
the Holy Grail of the kind of uh
research that I do but uh yeah it's true
about a decade ago as I was doing the
research for this book I came across an
unredacted version of what was even then
already a very famous letter the
existence of which had been established
uh in the 70s with the church committee
which was this Anonymous threatening
letter that the FBI had sent to king
during this critical period of his life
so that in many ways was the kind of uh
lowest moment of an incredibly extensive
campaign first of surveillance then of
disruption and harassment that the FBI
engaged in against King sort of started
out looking at a couple of his advisors
who were involved with the Communist
party and that was one way in that
turned into two wire Taps on many of his
associates which then turned into
wiretaps on King himself which then
turned into bugging his hotel rooms
which then LED them to evidence of his
extramarital sexual activity that they
were recording and so in this moment in
late 1964 Hoover both publicly denounced
King in a confrontation as quote the
most notorious liar in America it's an
interesting public confrontation and
then secretly the FBI put together
these tapes and this Anonymous kind of
dirty tricks letter purporting to come
from a disillusioned admirer that has
all sorts of details about King's sex
life is clearly meant to threaten him
either drive him out of public life or
as many people interpret it get him to
actually kill himself
um how Why didn't it work
yeah it's really interesting so the FBI
did a lot of peddling of this
information about King and particularly
about King's sex life two members of
Congress to members of the press during
this period and then of course uh
engaging in this mailing to King himself
and a lot of people you know just
thought it was kind of political
Dynamite they didn't want to touch it
the Press didn't want to print it there
are some kind of offhand references at
various moments in Congress and in the
Press uh there are a lot of urgent
meetings with other members of the Civil
Rights move and other leaders of the
Civil Rights Movement who really come to
the FBI I beg them to stop doing this
the FBI was a lot closer with you know
the NAACP and more kind of conventional
DC uh civil rights leaders and a lot of
them came and kind of pleaded with with
the bureau to stop doing it um which
they both both did and didn't but um it
didn't really become public in a
significant way
um what does said
um I mean does it suggest uh you know I
guess on the one hand it plainly shows
that Jagger Hoover was willing to go to
extreme lengths to discredit you know
his what he perceived as his political
adversaries on another level there's
some restraint there there right in that
he did not call a press conference and
make this public
um he did he he desisted after a certain
point right
um although uh as your book points out I
mean the the relationship between Jagger
Hoover and Robert Kennedy in particular
is vexed because Bobby Kennedy signed
off on many of these uh wiretaps or knew
all of this information and then later
kind of threw a Hoover under the bus or
or pretended that he was not implicated
in it
um but I mean it does this show like did
who Hoover learned something from the
failure to kind of unmask uh Martin
Luther King as a serial philanderer and
of course you know David Garrow and
other Martin Luther King biographers
have said there is you know more it's
it's not simply that King was sleeping
around I mean there's uh accounts of
sexual violence and whatnot that are
deeply troubling which have little or
nothing to do with King's civil rights
work but you know what what did Hoover
take away from the failure of
um you know of his uh uh attacks on King
you know and then the assassination of
King as well as Bobby Kennedy
um and Malcolm X and things like that
yeah well I think Hoover was frustrated
by his inability to uh in fact you know
bring down Martin Luther King or damage
his reputation
um but you also see him kind of
calculating in the documents about how
far this can be pushed without
discrediting the FBI I mean I think one
of the things that's really interesting
to me is that as you look at these kind
of behind the scenes records
um you see how many people in positions
of power did actually have some sense of
what the FBI was doing right it wasn't
publicly known but King certainly knew
about it other people in the movement
knew that they were being surveilled and
that there was lots of wiretapping and
bugging going on that the FBI was really
gunning for King Lyndon Johnson knew
major newspaper editors knew members of
Congress knew if only because they were
getting this information there's really
only one any way you get that
information you know and none of them uh
publicly denounced King but also none of
them went after Hoover either and so I
think he had a sense that he could do
quite a lot of this without himself
suffering
um political consequences either and and
of course he all throughout his career
but especially I guess starting maybe
not especially but in the 60s he also
started doing the outward facing public
relations stuff you spent a fair amount
of time uh talking about a TV show
called the FBI with Ephraim zibulus JR
this haunts the reruns of my childhood
uh you know of sick days and things like
that how did Hoover how how did Hoover
promote the vision of himself but also
the agency throughout the popular
culture because he seemed to be
incredibly Savvy at doing that
yeah it's true the people who came of
age in the in the 60s can and I say that
I'm writing about Hoover they often say
the FBI right do the kind of opening
segment of that series which was very
popular uh beginning in 1965. uh but
public relations were an absolutely key
part of his career of the FBI's
apparatus beginning in the 1930s uh you
know he was not only good at getting his
message out into the press and into
Hollywood and ultimately on TV but uh in
cultivating popular constituencies that
were going to support him you know one
of the savviest things I think that he
did was have a policy that uh you know
the FBI would kind of create some little
piece of propaganda about how great they
were and if a Small Town Newspaper
editor went ahead and published that
Hoover would have a letter sent to that
editor with his byline saying thank you
so much for this and then you know you
got a letter from the great J Edgar
Hoover and it was sort of This brilliant
thing that kept this big big popular
constituency of his quite loyal to him
um another point that you make that you
know kind of goes in Hoover's favor
again you know it's wrong it's not like
you're making the case for Jagger Hoover
as you know the greatest American or
anything but no I'm definitely not doing
it no no but I mean what what flushes
things out is um his uh engagement with
the mafia and this is you know or actual
organized crime one of the knocks on
Hoover was always that and uh you know
again I come from parents who you know
grew up you know Hoover was a great mad
you know uh he's uh like Robert Moses or
FDR Truman or whatever and
um you know one of the knocks on uh
Hoover was that he failed to take the
mafia seriously partly uh my mother was
Italian so her family who hated the
mafia but reveled in this was that he
thought Italians were too stupid to kind
of pull off a national organized crime
syndicate that's wrong right I I mean
it's not that he was you know
particularly prescient or laser focused
on stopping organized crime but what's
the revisionist take on Hoover's
understanding and treatment of the mafia
some truth to this you know
long-standing idea that he was pretty
slow to recognize the mafia as a kind of
formal crime syndicate he certainly had
all sorts of weird ideas about various
racial groups probably including
Italians so I didn't come across very
much of that
um and uh so you know there's some truth
to that but it's also clear that
beginning in the 1950s when you know
things like Appalachian which was a raid
on this kind of Mafia Khan Fab when
things like that start to happen Hoover
says okay okay and that was like The
Burning Man for Mafia exactly in the
middle of nowhere and upside New York
we're all having dinner together and
then fleeing into the woods when they're
yeah in their like tiny Italian thin
loafers exactly uh so you know in a
moment like that he he changes course
pretty quickly and one of the things
that starts happening in the late 50s
into early 6 60s is that the FBI has
some success in conducting pretty secret
operations particularly against the
Chicago mob they get uh you know they
actually get microphones into mob
headquarters I mean big things that
they're pretty proud of but they're not
the kinds of things that you can talk
about publicly so Hoover is not talking
about them publicly and there actually
is not a whole lot of federal
jurisdiction on this as much as there's
kind of public pressure and public
desire for it Hoover is a little bit
like you know what what are the laws
that we're actually going to use to uh
to prosecute he gets very mad when
Robert Kennedy comes in as attorney
general in the early 60s and says by
golly we're going to go after organized
crime and it really does ramp up at that
point but Hoover always thought it was a
little unfair uh to be criticizing the
FBI which had been doing some stuff at
least
um you know Hoover uh kind of like Elvis
had a bad 60s really right um you know
he tried to uh you know uh talk I guess
a bit about how the uh cointel Pro and
is is that the correct pronunciation or
is it cointelpro or is it I pronounce it
okay yeah you you are the historian so
I'll and and it comparts with my
pronunciation so let's go with that
um talk about how you know there there
was a version of that that went after
right-wing groups like the Ku Klux Klan
but the main focus were on you know
black power grips like the Black
Panthers
um and also the anti-warma or the new
Left particularly the anti-war movement
how did that work to kind of you know
and at this point Hoover is in his 70s
uh he has managed to get LBJ and other
people to kind of wave mandatory
retirement ages
um for him
how did that kind of show that I mean
he's he's like Frank Sinatra in a way
you know where he is trying to sing you
know Beatles songs but he just looks
really bad doing it how how did
cointelpro kind of show that he had lost
whatever understanding he might have had
on America uh you know in in the late
60s right well Hoover Uh certainly is
trying to talk to the new generation
though uh he is also conducting
surveillance of The Beatles among
everyone else yeah sure sure
um well they were subversive of
something maybe not of American virtue
but uh but cointelpro is I think you
know probably the most notorious program
of Hoover's career now was not publicly
known for most of his career
um but it stands for Counter
Intelligence program and it was as you
say largely aimed at groups on the left
uh the student activist movement the
anti-war movement civil rights black
power in particular a whole range of of
60s activist organizations and it was
not just a surveillance operation it was
deliberately an operation that was aimed
at causing kind of disruption and
paranoia getting movements and
organizations and leaders to fight with
themselves to become disorganized and
kind of to collapse from within I think
there are a couple of things that are
particularly interesting about it that
are a little bit less known one is that
it actually started in the 50s as an
operation aimed at the Communist party
and really you know a sense that uh
people didn't like prosecutions and such
So Much Anymore the Supreme Court was
kind of turning on the Red Scare so that
the FBI was going to have to do stuff
secretly
though it is also clear that they did
inform Dwight Eisenhower and Congress at
least in some general way that they were
engaged in these kind of disruptive
activities and nobody objected or said
much of anything about it as you say
there was a part of cointelpro that was
aimed at a far right and white
supremacist groups and it was exactly
the same kinds of methods that were
being deployed
deployed other groups so you know
disruption and formers going in and kind
of misguiding meetings fake press
reports sewing rumors you know all of
these kind of disruptive tactics and so
it's a really interesting lesson both in
in what happens uh kind of when there's
a whole secret operation but the ways in
which these methods move from one group
to another pretty easily yeah
um you know I think of the uh you know
of the FBI in the 60s also undertook
um at some expense at taxpayer expense
uh an investigation to figure out what
the lyrics to Louie Louie were and uh
word failed to do it I mean I guess this
is uh before we talk briefly about his
life and his uh you know his kind of
personal life and what came after him
you know is there yeah I mean do you
consider Hoover a success or or how do
you you know how do you deal with that
because in many ways like his you know
when I read your biography and it's
funny you mentioned the Beatles like
when when I read a Beatles biography you
know like a lot of people I'm obsessive
about that and I find every detail
interesting and then I'm kind of like
okay well is that all they did after you
know a 900 page book
um and they changed the world they were
you know all of this kind of stuff
Hoover probably you know discussed the
question of the American Century to the
extent that the American Century
happened he is one of the main players
in this he created as much of kind of
20th century you know America as anyone
was he successful or how do you measure
whether the FBI was good bad or
indifferent when you take the measure of
his life
yeah well I think there are a lot of
ways to to measure that I mean the book
opens with a moment in 1959 when this
big Hollywood movie called the FBI story
is coming out and it's sort of a grand
vision of Hoover's Bureau over 30 35
years and it suggests you know if Hoover
had retired in 1959 he would be
remembered very differently than he is
now and I think that we would answer
this question was he a success
differently
um you know I'm pretty critical of some
of the things that he did during the Red
Scare and to the Communist party but he
was incredibly popular for doing that
and uh it's only in the 60s that he
begins to really lose some of his
popularity that things polarize and
fracture and his reputation takes a big
hit
um so he was certainly successful at
staying in office because he was there
until the day he died I think in many
ways Days by his own terms he was
successful at kind of policing and
enforcing certain boundaries to American
democracy and I think that was kind of
his political goal in educated deciding
who was legitimate who was illegitimate
I think a lot of the movements of the
50s and 60s would have gone differently
without the FBI's involvement and uh you
know he didn't Crush those movements but
he certainly changed them and contained
them in various ways no I don't think
that's a particularly good thing other
people might think you want to call that
a success of sorts and I think that he
was
quite successful at building an
institution with a lot of staying power
in the government that even today 50
years after his death you know Bears the
stamp of his priorities and his ideas to
some degree again do we want to talk
about that as like arousing success that
that's a that's a sort of subjective
judgment yes but but he did in many ways
what he set out to do
um briefly uh let's talk a little bit
about his personal life
um you know and this is something where
I I guess it's really I mean these
rumors were floating around during his
life
um and even in what I think was the
first biography of him written by a
conservative writer Ralph de toledano
who read for National Review and was
actually a member of Jim Garrison's
office that tried clay
um uh I'm sorry uh uh
clay the businessman
uh and whatnot but um you know was
Hoover gay in any meaningful way that we
can talk about and and does that matter
yeah I would say yes and no which might
be an unsatisfying answer so it's clear
during his lifetime you know he never
had a significant relationship with a
woman
um all of his significant relationships
were with men and the most important by
far was with Clyde toolson who was his
number two at the FBI but was also
really his social partner and spouse
that traveled together had all their
meals together Etc so you know that's
all very clear and that's pretty much
out in the open I mean that's it's very
well documented there's not much
question yeah and you document how you
know uh you know Richard and Pat Nixon
would go out with them and then send
notes saying like a thanks to you and
Clyde for a wonderful I mean they were
treated as a married couple exactly
exactly in Washington in L.A in New York
um that's how they that's how they moved
through their lives so what can we then
say about that uh they themselves of
course did not describe themselves as
being gay and uh they were part of the
you know enforcement apparatus for
purges of gay people from the federal
government
um they we don't know if they were
having sex right we just don't know that
uh we can't know that we will probably
never know that
um and that gives me a small measure of
relief I have to say things you don't
know too much about you yeah you know
I'm okay with that one being gray but
um and you know it's also clear that
Hoover kind of policed in a very
aggressive way any rumors about his own
sexuality and so uh there are moments
where you know someone's at a party they
mentioned they've heard this rumor about
the director and there was a lot of that
at the time uh and that you know they
would get an FBI agent showing up at
their door saying you should never say
such scurrilous things about our fine
upstanding FBI director
um so so that's kind of the obverse of
if you're a Small Town Newspaper editor
and you get the the letter from Jagger
Hoover exactly either get that or you
get the FBI guide you're doing what he
wants or not doing what he wants and he
had both you know the the the fist he is
Santa Claus he knows if you're you know
he's watching you right that's that's
what he wanted
um yeah so you know I think in the end I
do think it's useful to think of uh of
Hoover as uh a gay man in the sense that
clearly his deepest affinities and
affections were for other men and I
think that he and Tolson you know loved
each other and and and functioned as
life partners for each other but beyond
that it's hard to say it's not language
of their own relationship
and I I mean I guess this would be a
different conversation but if uh Hoover
lived in a time when homosexuality was
more accepted it might have changed not
only his conception of himself but of
masculinity and the way that he kind of
projected that onto law enforcement or
the institution that he created
um there is no evidence that he is a
cross-dresser is that correct
there is no evidence that I think we
would recognize as real historical
evidence
um there were rumors there are people
who purport to have seen things but
they're not super reliable Witnesses and
those stories mostly start cropping up
after he died right
um I mean I'm always from from the point
of view of kind of how myths become real
um it's always fascinating that
um the the cross-dressing stuff usually
gets sourced to a kind of down market
British writer writing sometime after
Hoover died that's kind of the first
print version of this right it's mostly
from a biography by a British journalist
named Anthony Summers that came out in
the early 90s so it's it's 20 years
after Cooper's death and of course he's
not around to say whether these things
were true
and that it was popularized in the uh
the Oliver Stone movie JFK
um right it seemed to be flooding around
and they had caught on immediately I
mean it is still one of the first things
that people ask me about Hoover
that must be great where you have
amassed a you know 800 page or 700 Page
biography and the people what they
really want to know is what size did he
wear right
uh and where did he buy his shoes
um why are you interested in this uh
you've written about political violence
uh and and kind of the you know the
anxiety around that um why um why are
you interested in Hoover or in this
broader part of American society and
history
yeah well I got interested in Hoover
writing my last book which was about a
bomb attack on Wall Street in 1920 and
the kind of history of radical terrorism
during that period and what was
interesting to me was that he was there
as a very young man already doing this
kind of work and I could see these ideas
kind of spreading throughout the rest of
the century
um so I guess a couple of things
interest me uh one is that I think he
shows the real centrality of
anti-communism or the struggle over
communism to nearly every aspect of
American politics over the course of the
20th century I think he turns our eye a
little bit away from you know presidents
and elections of political parties and
all of these important things about
politics to this other really important
story of what happened in the 20th
century which is the growth of the
federal government trying to make sense
of the relationship between the social
welfare state and the Security State and
the administrative state right all of
these big things that aren't always as
sexy as elections but are really really
important to think about and then I also
you know wanted to say something
different about Hoover himself because I
think there has been a tendency to kind
of cast him as a rogue villain and one
of these figures if only we had known
you know these things never would have
happened but the truth is that he was
very popular he was widely supported on
both sides of the aisle and so I think
you know if there are things that we
didn't like about Hoover and what he did
and how he built the FBI and the state
we have to actually look at this broader
history as much as we you know make him
into this simulator
isn't it a brutal irony and I mean I
certainly think that conservative or
conservatives in particular but also
maybe liberals and progressives and
Libertarians that you know one of the
reasons why the American state grew as
vastly as it did in the 20th century is
because it was trying to undermine
communism
um and so it becomes this mirror image
of it this is actually kind of the
thesis of Arthur E Kirch in a book in
the mid 50s called the decline of
American liberalism that in fighting
communism with a Garrison State we end
up becoming more and more like the
Soviet Union without kind of
acknowledging that
um and I find you know your book
certainly kind of suggests something
along those lines I wouldn't say that's
the main argument by any stretch
um yeah on that point to jump in I also
wanted to to think a little bit about
the history of conservatism because we
tend to you know describe the
conservative movement as being
anti-federal or anti-statist in some way
and yet here was J Edgar Hoover this art
of conservative in fact a hero of the
conservative movement who is really deep
within the state during this whole
period that we talk about as kind of the
Heyday of liberalism and that that set
of issues is really fascinating to me
yeah and what what do you make of the
Contemporary moment you know and I just
uh a couple of like an hour before we
started talking I was reading about how
you know the FBI was working so closely
with Twitter uh in terms of trying to
manage or massage certain types of the
reach of certain types of people or
Banning them all together
books like Timothy wieners uh enemies
which is a history of the FBI that came
out about a decade ago posits not only
is the FBI a effectively a criminal
organization within the government but
that it has gotten worse since Jagger
Hoover that you know I mean which was
kind of like the mind-blowing revolution
Revelation is that Hoover was terrible
and he might not even be in the top
three worst FBI heads what do you think
about the FBI since Hoover
um you know and and you mentioned the
church commission
um or church committee um you know we
didn't understand a lot of what was
going on in Hoover's FBI until the 70s
and those commissions uh Rockefeller
also ran one you know which revealed so
many extra legal illegal just you know
criminal acts by the FBI or the CIA the
NSA all in the interest of reining them
in that doesn't seem to have worked very
well it just seems to have kind of given
them new ways of figuring out how to to
get around whatever limits are placed on
them by the Constitution or by Congress
well this is uh you know it's a critical
history of Hoover I'm not sure I'm as
critical of the FBI
um as as that description would suggest
but you know I do think that the FBI is
in a position now where they're
encountering a lot of issues that would
be really familiar to Hoover so one is
that you're supposed to be this
apolitical organization and you're being
drawn into these incredibly politicized
investigations right from from Trump uh
to January 6th and that is to uh I mean
the Hillary in 2016. I mean James Comey
you know she still says that he he cost
her the election exactly and so you know
Hoover would have recognized that I
think there are all sorts of questions
about surveillance and infiltration
right whether you're talking about uh
the FBI and black lives matter or you're
talking about you know calls for them to
be more aggressive toward groups on the
right uh you know that I think is all
deeply resonant with this other period
And I think that the FBI still kind of
does the things that Hoover set it up to
do you know it's law enforcement and
domestic intelligence it is has this
kind of it's being provocative I mean in
the trial of the people uh you know
accused of planning to kidnap Gretchen
Whitmer the Michigan Governor you know
they were like oh you know there were a
bunch of federal informants in here who
were actually the ones like no no do it
this way do it this way so right those
issues came up uh uh a lot during
Hoover's period particularly in kind of
plan investigations that sort of thing
um and you know I think the FBI still
has this kind of tension between on the
one hand uh kind of professional
scientific expert identity and then on
the other hand you know certain kinds of
pretty powerful conservative
institutional culture and these things
kind of spin around uh together as they
did as they did then I mean the funny
thing at the moment is that Democrats
now like the FBI so much more than
Republicans do which has not happened in
half a century but we're saying yeah
that and the you know shifting kind of
valences of Russia in you know in
American political discourse it's like
you know so we now have a Republican
party that is objectively pro-putin and
anti-fbi it's kind of like I must have
missed the season you know where that
plot line got introduced and turned
around do you uh I I guess as a final
question and and this might be on beyond
your purview one of the things that is
phenomenal about the book beyond its
absolute readability and it's you know
attention to detail and your
unwillingness to go beyond what the
historical record shows I I guess my
question is is it conceivable or or can
we conceive of a federal agency that
does what the the FBI is supposed to do
that does not get politicized or does
not overreach in kind of predictable
ways and recurrent ways because all
again and I think you know your your
book does a fantastic job of laying out
all of the tensions within Hoover and
within the institution that he created
um you know sometimes he went by the
letter of the law other times he didn't
he pulled back he refused to do
political work for Richard Nixon which
in an interesting way gives us Watergate
which in an interesting way gives us the
church commission which tells us that
jager Hoover was not a good guy for most
of his career it was very an ambivalent
figure
um is is there a way to conceive of a
federal intelligence agency or Bureau
that does not become what the FBI seems
to have become which is this endlessly
politicized
professionalized kind of vague
institution that is you know is never
quite what it's supposed to be
well I think that the FBI structurally
you know is going to be drawn in uh in
some of those directions always and so
it's a question of what kind of limits
and accountability and transparency are
going to look like and that was what the
church committee was trying to do what
the reforms of the 70s were trying to do
did it successfully to some degree some
of that was undone in the wake of 9 11
right so we've had a number of different
ways of of kind of thinking about
accountability and transparency you know
I would say from Hoover's era that the
impulses that led to the greatest abuses
were tended to happen in two areas one
was when Hoover and therefore the
institution that he was a part of uh and
was directing when they had such a
powerful sense of their own
righteousness of their own correctness
that they understood themselves to be
kind of acting for a cause and therefore
anyone who was critical or disagreed
with them was suspect right so that
sense of really powerful uncritical
self-righteousness uh tended to drive a
lot of the biggest abuses and excesses
and then part of what enabled that to
happen was an apparatus of secrecy where
the FBI could say well I don't know how
popular this will be or I don't know if
we really have jurisdiction for this but
we're right and therefore we'll just do
it in secret we'll figure out a way to
to carry this out and I think both of
those certainly in the Hoover era were
were the places where the bureau made
its greatest missteps uh its greatest
moments of kind of overreach and abuse
so those are those are probably features
just to to watch for in the present as
well
um the book has been extremely well
received it's shown up on various
bestseller lists and best of the Year
lists and things like that I'm curious
among your historian Brethren your
professional historian Brethren are
people like I wish I hadn't written that
or are they like you know this really is
making me think harder and deeper about
the way that we do history
but people mostly seem to be willing to
think hard and long and it is a long
book about JF Hoover and I wasn't
entirely sure that that was going to be
the case we've had pretty fixed ideas
about him for a pretty long period of
time but I'm happy to say that I think
most people have uh been been ready to
to kind of open up and I think for
historians you know we're we're
generally pretty glad when um when
projects that take you know 13 years of
research and all these documents
actually that everyone reads them you
know it's kind of a win for everyone
whenever that happens so well it
certainly is a win for the the American
reading public and I hope people in
government read this as well uh or at
least have it read to them in summary
form Beverly Gage uh thank you so much
for writing G magic or Hoover in the
making of the American Century and for
talking to reason okay thanks for having
me
thank you